good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP eight
special containment procedures SCP eight
eleven should be kept in a
climate-controlled cylindrical glass
enclosure between ten and twenty meters
in diameter filled to a depth of no less
than two and a half meters on average
with wetland soil and stagnant
freshwater it is to be furnished with a
variety of aquatic plants from its
native swamp it has the remaining
vegetation there has exhibited the
adaptation to regrow quickly from
injuries injured during contact with SCP
a 11 as long as the roots are undamaged
logs of manageable size and additional
humans rich soil may be provided for
good behavior water depth is not to
exceed half a meter at its lowest point
height of the enclosure must be no less
than five meters above the highest soil
point temperature is to be kept at 25
degrees Celsius and humidity should be
kept above 70% there is to be a
decontamination airlock chamber between
the door into the enclosure and the door
to the rest of the facility air that is
ventilated into the enclosure should not
be recirculated back into the rest of
the facility under any circumstances
the methane resulting from SCP Adel
Evans normal interaction with this
environment is not anomalous sand may be
bottled for uses fuel no heated elements
or open flames are permitted inside the
enclosure the enclosure must be tested
daily for pH and microbe levels in both
the soil and water as well as for
changes in chemical composition
enclosure should be cleaned by weekly
preferably by d-class personnel all
discarded waste should be put in
quarantine for analysis before disposal
by standard biohazard protocol
subject is to be given at least five
kilograms of live food 24 hours after
its completion of its previous meal the
subject is not averse to preying on
humans and that is recommended that
personnel not enter the enclosure of
SCPA 11 has not fed in over 16 hours
no invasive medical procedure may be
performed on SCP at 11 outside of
emergency situations in which such a
procedure is required to save a subjects
life minimally invasive procedures
require review and unanimous approval by
SCP 8 Elevens assigned medical team and
the current project head see document
811 B for a list of substances that may
be administered as medication to SCP at
11:00 all requests by the subject are to
be reviewed by both an overseeing animal
enrichment specialist and at least one
level 3 personnel before approval and
the review should not take more than 48
hours unless exceptional circumstances
dictate otherwise while SCP and 11 is
not generally aggressive unless it feels
hungry or threatened all handling
personnel are to be cautioned that it is
still an opportunistic ambush predator
and safety precautions must still be
taken to avoid injury and/or infection
all personnel entering the enclosure
must wear full-body non organic
biohazard suits and breath masks and
must be in groups of at least 2 no
personnel arts you enter the enclosure
if they have open wounds or sores
anywhere on their body though suffering
from asthma or other respiratory
affecting conditions are prohibited from
entering the enclosure without a signed
note from a physician with level 4
security clearance as far as research
indicates SCP at 11 cannot cause serious
injury to anyone properly wearing their
biohazard suit anyone who removes any
part of their biohazard suit while still
in the enclosure for any reason at all
will still be subject to disciplinary
action up to an including reassignment
to a project that would not be adversely
affected by their status as an amputee
description as CP 811 is shaped
similarly to a human female with
disproportionately long and thin limbs
in a slightly bloated abdominal region
it is 171 centimeters tall and weighs
just under 47 kilograms
due to its strange physiology see
addendum 811 - for details its skin has
slight abrasive properties and is a
model of green color that serves to
camouflage it among the reeds in its
natural habitat its sweat has been
observed to act as a mild skin irritant
it has extremely oily black hair that
has proven to be resistant to cleaning
with conventional shampoos see addendum
811 one it shows partial comprehension
of human language consistent with case
studies of feral children that had been
abandoned at a few years old instead of
as infants the Palmer punter services of
SCP a to leaven skin constantly secrete
a clear green tinted mucous with minor
adhesive properties this mucus does not
appear to have any effect on SCP at 11
zone tissue but any other organic matter
that it comes into contact with begins
to rapidly decompose through processes
not fully understood reducing the matter
into a slightly viscous black liquid SCP
a ttle evan can then absorb said liquid
through its skin and directly into its
circulatory system tests have shown that
SCP eight Elevens entire circulatory
system is filled with liquefied decaying
matter biopsies taken from a CP 811 has
shown the presence of anaerobic bacteria
in all examines cells which due to the
apparent lack of anything resembling
functional red blood cells in the
subject are currently presumed to be
what SCP adel evan uses to metabolize
the chemicals in a circulatory system
SCP 811 does not defecate or otherwise
produce feces in the traditional sense
and entirely lacks a small or large
intestine instead cellular waste and
substances SCP 8 11 is unable to
metabolize collect in what is
anatomically speaking its stomach
within the stomach enzymes and bacterial
flora caused it to congeal into a grainy
tar-like substance that SCP adel evan
periodically voids by voluntary
projectile regurgitation a mechanism
which it uses to hunt it preferentially
aims at the face or at any perceived
open wounds on its target then waits for
the target to die of either immediate
asphyxiation by blockage of the mouth
and nose or in a few days of multi
systemic failure resulting from
aggressive bacterial infection SCP in
Elevens teeth did not seem to have any
abnormal resistance to decay resulting
from chronic exposure to the compounds
in micro flora in its waste see addendum
811 one prognosis for a personnel who
have had contact with SCP eight Elevens
waste through mucous membrane or open
wound is good if broad-spectrum
antibiotic therapy has begun in the
first three hours but then rapidly
declines personnel who are d-class or
have gone 12 hours without getting
treatment may request termination
addendum 811 1 to date
SCP 811 has requested regular delivery
of bovine pray denied that crocodilians
be removed from its prey animal rotation
approved the water be stumped with a
variety of fish species from its native
denied one hairbrush made from 100%
synthetic materials approved for one
d-class personnel to every other day
come in with a basin and showerhead to
wash and condition its hair approved it
has been noted that standard strength
hair shampoos do not adequately clean
away the excessive oil in a CPA and
Elevens hair and the use of a formula
with a higher proportion of stronger
surfactants has been authorized to be
addressed by a two-syllable name that
has been translated as a SCP a 11 being
illiterate and thus not capable of
choosing a spelling for itself
sidenote due to SCPA 11th difficulty
with language
it has been deemed acceptable to use its
chosen name when directly speaking to it
for the purpose of streamlining
meaningful conversation relief from its
chronic tooth pain approved request was
initially denied until a safe and
effective method of administering
general anesthesia to SCP an 11 was
discovered and a dental surgery plan
devised tooth number 47 f di two-digit
rotation removed to test method and
adjust for unpredicted special aftercare
requirements remainder of a CPA Levin's
teeth removed and over denture implants
installed in a second operation as CP
811 supplied with complete dentures to
be repaired as needed one turtle in a
hazmat suit for non dietary purposes
denied Turtles accordingly removed from
prey animal rotation possibility of
placing a small turtle habitat in the
observation area out sinus cp8 Elevens
enclosure for enrichment under
consideration
addendum 8:11 - due to the fact that a
CP 811 has lungs and teeth despite
having no apparent use for either it was
brought to by a research area twelves
radiology lab for x-rays to examine its
internal structure results were
inconclusive
subsequent MRI testing has revealed that
SCP Adel Evan has a number of unusual
glands and organs attached to its
lymphatic system which may assist in
regulation of the viscosity and
microbial flora of the material in its
circulatory system one such organ in the
abdominal region appears to contain
lighter-than-air gas the possibility
that as CP 811 was wonderful is being
explored due to the impossibility of
maintaining a sterile operating
environment limited understanding of SCP
a to Levin's biology and difficulty in
calculating the subjects mass the risk
of major complications or subject death
has been deemed too high to authorize
exploratory surgery
and this is interview log 811 16
interviewers dr. trebuchet and junior
lab assistant walk tall dr. Travis
interests cp8 11th containment unit
dr. trebuchet is carrying a clipboard of
the document on it at the shoe box a
rookie I told questions points to shoe
box
dr. trebuchet nods hand opens the shoe
box a frog jumps out as CP 811 bricks
her foot down when the Frog as a land
and begins to digest it look felines
Christmas yes as the clip on to water
points to something I'd reading from the
cut board was the earliest thing you can
remember I early things things before
you for books before the box must be for
yes
with sweeping a demonstrative arm and
hand movement became an door I he's
small very smaller and man uses hand to
indicate a height of approximately one
meter off the ground points to her own
are like man what was like him which is
the santur seen between two fingers both
look alike are you like a man like
people your skin part out on
thoughtfully then smiles still why do
you mean you had skin like ours
so a1 after pointing to the inside of
one elbow babe here Holt needle a tether
they're called needles and then pain
pantomiming something coming out of her
mouth skin at this point what to begins
to vomit in his hands mad suit as CP
8:11 misinterpreting this as a sign of
hostility retreats into one of the pools
of water in its enclosure and does not
resurface until both wattle and dr.
trebuchet have left notes while I
understand the appeal of training the
new blood on something relatively
harmless and as green as they are could
you please throw them at some other
humanoid it for a while I'm trying to
actually get things done here dr. Trevor
shake Sonia
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
goodbye
hello everyone Lumi here first of all
welcome thank you so much for testing me
for this role I had such fun coming up
with the accent for ie and know for the
advertisement part if you guys would
like to hear me read story sing songs
and do some other small things follow a
link down below to my youtube channel or
if you are more of a stream person you
can follow another link down below to my
twitch stream actually I should be
streaming around the time this video is
released maybe I'll see some of you guys
there have a nice night everyone bye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob vermut Jim's Sabha arbiter Sewell
dr. bright Darius Tom Maximus Decimus
Justin day Oh philia gray dur Nam
Alex Hill and jayvo Jack quarry Barker
Arun in and dr. Proctor thank you all so
much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you